live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by best-selling author and Ramsey
personality Christina Ellis and it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money Samuel
kicks us off this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina Samuel welcome to the
show
hey guys how you going how are you doing
man how can we help okay doing pretty
good so I guess my main question is I'm
moving out from my parents house soon to
the State of Florida if my girlfriend
lives there so we're planning to get
married and my question is this would be
my first place on my own would it be
better to go for an apartment lease or
try and do a mortgage because honestly
the prices are only a couple hundred
dollars difference uh depending on like
a small house versus like a one bedroom
apartment so I'm just trying to figure
out the best route to get there what's
your timeline on things so you're moving
to Florida when's that happening you're
gonna marry your girlfriend when's that
happening what's that look like
uh my plan is to move there sometime
this spring and then get married around
the end of the year
okay so initially when you move there
you're going to be living by yourself
for a while right
yes exactly are you gonna have a
roommate
uh that's what I'm trying to figure out
are you pretty I'm not I'm not against
it but I don't really know anyone there
yet so we're gonna see you okay are you
pretty familiar with the area of Florida
that you're moving to
yeah I've been I've visited a couple
different or probably like 10 times at
least so I do know I do know the area
pretty well okay and what's your
financial situation what's your income
yeah so right now I I run my own video
production
um agency awesome it is um my own
business but I do have a couple like
retainer clients so it is
um sort of guaranteed income on contract
and so anywhere right now from around 50
to 60 000
cool and you would keep that business
running if you moved to Florida is it
something you can do remotely
yes uh most of it is remote but I do
have enough time to go out and do
physical jobs around the area that sort
of stuff cool well Samuel this is all
super exciting like moving out of the
parents house getting married this is
this is awesome how old are you yeah I'm
18. wow you're a stud dude all right how
much debt do you have yeah I have no
debt right now uh the only payments I'm
doing are just car insurance uh phone
bills and a couple other subscriptions
around about 300 uh 300 a month cool and
then how much money do you have in the
bank
uh right now I have around 5 000 saved
up
um so not too much so that's why I'm
trying to trying to figure out is that
just enough to get you moved and you
know first month last month deposits all
that kind of stuff
yes but I do have
um a lot of gigs already signed on and
contracted for this year it's just a
matter of getting it done and getting
paid for it okay so back to your
original question should you buy or
should you rent you should absolutely
rent and not just because you don't have
money for the down payment right now but
also because we don't know the area
you're going to get married at the end
of the year so I would sign probably you
know a year lease when you get over
there and you're not even engaged yet
right
no not yet no but you still think you're
going to propose and be married before
2023 is over
that's the plan yeah this guy's got a
lot of drive for 18. a lot of respect
for Samuel I love it hey Samuel if I'm
in your shoes that's how we often answer
these questions because you know right
now you've got a wide open space there's
so many different ways you can go but if
I'm in your shoes I'm going to try to
get as little obligation and stress as
possible so I love what George said
about a roommate I'd be looking online
you know joining Facebook communities
maybe networking with your friends see
if they know anybody in the area maybe
your girlfriend knows someone and see if
you can just be a roommate to somebody
who already has a lease like that leads
to your options open yeah it just okay
kind of the stress off of it now when it
comes to buying a house you don't need a
credit score but you will need rental
history and so make sure that you have
good track record of you're making a
consistent monthly payment on time
you've got a few trade lines open like
you mentioned your your cell phone bill
something you're paying consistently
every single month your internet bills
those subscriptions they're going to be
looking for things like that just to
prepare you for it for the time you are
ready to buy a house and also like with
your girlfriend there's going to be so
many factors with the home buying
process like you're you're going to get
married eventually right and so she's
going to have her opinions on the house
she's gonna you know want certain
wallpaper a certain layout and so being
able to make that decision together once
you're married is gonna you know just
involve her in the process you're not
gonna get locked into a house that maybe
you know in a year once you're married
she's like I don't like this house I'm
gonna go somewhere else oh yeah yeah and
when you get married man it's a lot of
life change at once so I'd even
encourage you guys to rent for a year
you're probably gonna need more time
just to save up because you got to save
up for a wedding too in the next year
and we don't know who's going to be
paying for what you're gonna have to buy
an engagement ring so there's a lot of
life expenses coming up that I would be
focused on before home ownership you'll
get there you're going to get there way
before most of America will ever get
there at 18 with no debt making 60k and
so I'd continue to just try to live on
as little as you can for the next year
as you get married and maybe you sign a
lease and then she he joins and you kick
the roommate out that's always a fun
game to play so that's an option as well
you can think about
well and I got you awesome you're in
such a great spot now the fact that you
were calling the Ramsey Show at 18 you
know on the front end of all these
decisions that is awesome and I think we
get in the spot a lot of times you know
especially when you're young it feels
like you need to hurry like you need to
hurry you need to get the house you need
to get married and all these different
things and I think it's awesome that
you're getting married but with some of
these other things you don't have to be
in too big of a rush right you don't
have to lock yourself into a long-term
mortgage like you can make a big step in
moving to Florida but you don't have to
like have every single thing figured out
straight away so your next goal Samuel
is we've gotta get this move done let's
figure out what our rent situation looks
like then we're going to start make sure
we have an emergency fund in place of
three to six months of expenses once you
know what those are going to be then
we're going to be saving up for the
engagement ring then we're going to be
planning for the wedding and paying for
that then once all that's over and we
have a new situation in this marriage we
can then focus on saving up that down
payment and I want you to have at least
10 percent down I love 20 or more
because you can avoid pm my and only get
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage and it's
so easy to get tempted by the 30-year
and say well we'll pay it off like a 15
and it gives us wiggle room I don't play
that game how about we get a 15 and pay
it off like a seven and by the time
you're you know 27 years old you've got
a paid for a house
and the rest of your life ahead of you
with your bride
well most beautiful too at this age at
18 just starting their lives getting
married like these are your textbook
baby step millionaires right in 15 years
you all are going to be killing it
you're walking into your 30s with a paid
off house with a huge retirement account
like that is your future if you follow
these steps how did you hear about this
stuff Samuel I'm curious
yeah I mean I I have a a friend of mine
who used to work at Ramsey and so he
sort of introduced me to the different
things and then um I just started
watching the YouTube videos and I was
just watching it while I was eating
lunch and I'm like I should call in and
just just see what they have to say I
love it I love watching the highlight
videos that's awesome man well we
appreciate that our YouTube Team
especially appreciates that such an
awesome vehicle to get people who may
not know about us to go oh this stumbled
upon this and with all the just trash
stuff on the internet and social media
and Tick Tock and YouTube We're Going
Upstream here with some counter cultural
advice which is not get rich quick it's
get rich slow slow down use wisdom pay
cash for things and you wouldn't believe
the hate we get for just saying that
basic stuff but it's gods and grandmas
ways of handling money it's the Ramsay
show and you can join the conversation
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Christina Ellis
this hour open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Courtney joins us up next in Jackson
Tennessee Courtney welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help today
so I'm like super upside down on my car
and I am in babysit number two and it's
actually my highest debt but it's just
it's causing me so much trouble not the
vehicle but the payment itself is just
outrageous so I'm trying to figure out
what to do as far as you know my vehicle
goes how much do you owe on the car
um I owe about thirty two thousand okay
and what is it worth right now
eighteen thousand oh
how how did it get to this point what'd
you buy the car for
um after interest and stuff it was forty
nine thousand dollars
so you paid 49 for it what was it worth
of the time you bought you think it was
worth 49
um I don't remember I want to say it was
like 35 or so and
um the interest is I think is an
interest is what got it all messed up
what's your payment and what's your
interest rate
rp688 a month uh yeah it's rough
yesterday is 12 point I'm sorry 15.12
percent
why did you get such a terrible interest
rate
honestly I'm not sure because this was
the first vehicle I ever financed and
before like after that I got other debt
but before the car I had like three
thousand dollars in student loans and
that was like all that was on my credit
oh my goodness what's the what's the
term for this how long
is the loan for six years six years what
kind of car is it
a 2018 Volkswagen Tiguan okay how long
have you had it
eight months and that's how like d can I
load the value is going in eight months
it's gone down that quickly or do you
think he bought it a little too too high
priced maybe I bought it you know but I
was just thinking wow you know the
decrease in value I guess we sold this
car too
the dealership I worked for no oh yeah
was it like a A co-worker that's a
friend or or how did that happen
yeah it is a friend but I don't work in
the sales department I work in the
service department but yeah it was a
friend and I I don't I'm not sure like
you know have you talked to them about
this
I have
um what did they say and I think that
pretty much they're telling me like at
the time like the market was just so
messed up on cars
have you had any like Frank
conversations with them like asking kind
of like what was the value of the car
when you sold it to me
I haven't but that is a good idea I'm
actually on my lunch breaker you know so
I could do that when I come back here
there's no way that Carver's worth 49.5
when you bought it which is how much
you're paying with all these payments
and actually it was like 55 after I put
the I got I did get all the warranties
and things on it but how long have you
worked you can return that warranty
right and get some money back out of
this
yeah I could return the warranty how
much would that give you back
um probably about maybe five thousand
okay and how much money do you have in
the bank
um I have about 2 000 in my checking
account and other than that I just have
a thousand dollars for an emergency fund
okay
how long have you worked for this
dealership
about a year now
do you feel like in general they
typically have pretty good integrity
emotion time yeah yeah and and the my
co-worker he's actually a friend of mine
and
you know my friends don't screw me over
at 15 interest that's what I was
thinking too is like I feel like I've
been screwed over on it and you know
financially that's that's a big I want
to know how much this guy made off this
deal
yeah probably a lot and you know I'm 22
so I'm not trying to be stuck in this
for seven years
so the 18 000 value that you say your
car has like is that from Kelley Blue
Book is that somebody your job that said
that
KBB is that private party or trade-in
yes that's private party
okay I'm gonna still do some more
homework and research every single place
that buys used cars and that's online
that's local dealerships to see how much
you could get for this maybe even try
listing it and see if you can get more
for it
I
may not be the best advice but if I'm in
your shoes
boss and I'm saying here's the situation
how is this car that I just bought eight
months ago for this price now worth 18
and kind of walk through the situation
with your co-worker because my hope is
that as your employer there's some
sliver of heart there that maybe they'll
even consider buying it back from you at
a higher rate right closer to what you
paid for it right
yeah there's gonna be stupid texts on
this either way the only other option
here to get out from under this thing uh
soon is if you went to your local credit
union and get a personal loan for 14 000
to cover the difference
right and now you're 14 000 in debt
instead of thirty two thousand in debt
at a much lower interest rate
and I have other debt but it's just it's
seventy eight hundred dollars and I
could pay that off pretty quick
but I'm thinking long term like oh well
it's gonna take me years to get out of
debt with this car where's the 78 come
from because I thought you said you only
had 3 000 in debt when you got the car
well I had three thousandth a time and
this was a stupid decision but after I
got this car I started started getting
all these um
uh things in the mail like oh you're
approved today for this and that and
this and that and at the time I was just
like Oh yay extra money and I took out
personal loans but I've never done that
again I've learned my lesson because the
interest rates on them are outrageous
and I actually
um had like a two thousand dollar loan
that ended up being like 4 500 dollars
overall so
well I I'm assuming that you've had your
I've had it moment that you're done with
that yes I've had it I'm too young to be
stressed about this I've got goals and
I'm like no I'm trying to get out of all
this while I can heck yeah well start
ripping up your mail and if it says zero
percent or if it looks like free money
run as far as you can because there's no
such thing as a free lunch yeah there is
no free money I thought I learned that
the hard way they are not your friend
and by the way this dealership is not
your friend
yeah I I thought about that what are you
making at this dealership
I make about 50 000 a year okay
do you have any credit cards right now
I don't I actually paid that was my
number one baby steps or in the baby
steps number two the first thing I did
was pay off a credit card I owed like
288 on it I paid it I called I canceled
and I I'm out of the credit card
situation okay so this 50 000 is that
your only job you've got one job right
now
I do only have one job I've been
searching I've been listening to y'all
and a lot of people are talking about
like doordash and I've been considering
doing like a part-time doordash job just
something to get a little more money to
try to pay it off faster yeah you can
also look into grocery delivery services
like instacart or shipped
um you can even try Amazon Flex if
that's in your area to deliver packages
on your own schedule and you can make
some good money doing that
yeah and right now with where you're at
I know you're mad that like you're in
this situation at 22 years old like you
said you've got goals you need to get
out of this so I want you to take that
anger that you feel and that frustration
and just Channel all of it into doing
everything you can to get rid of the
stat I want you working 60 80 hours a
week I want you cutting back to the bare
minimum eating you know as cheaply as
possible like we have got to go scorched
Earth on this
yeah for sure and I have been I've got
the app that you guys uh talk about I've
been budgeting it's just like I was just
trying to think about the long run and
what I could do about my car we'll see
if if you can talk to the dealership and
go Hey listen you guys screwed me on
this deal and I work here and that is
not cool to treat an employee that way
so here's what I'm asking trade in this
car give me the crappiest car on your
lot to get me out of this situation and
if you still need to go take a small
personal loan from that credit union to
cover this mess and get out of this
thing then do that and then we're
attacking the rest of the debt while
driving this beater car until it's all
done
yeah I'll do that I'm down to drive a
beater car whatever it takes to get out
of you know and stand up for yourself
Courtney don't take crap from these guys
and I'd be leaving this dealership as
soon as I'm out of this mess because I
don't trust these people
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour this is the Ramsey show
you can give us a call at Triple Eight
825-5225
college and further education and saving
for college and getting out of that
student loan debt and what about student
loan forgiveness Christina is the expert
on that subject and would be happy to
jump in and help you with those calls
all right Christina so earlier this week
as I've been hosting we covered some
stupid tax moments which is what we call
you know financial decisions that we
regret that have some zeros on the end
we read somewhere off the internet that
were funny and sad Jade and I shared
some of our own stupid tax moments and I
thought Christina is perfect and it
turns out no it's a lie you had a little
stupid tax moment I how does very
recently right so we're doing no spend
month right we've not been spending
anything aside from Essentials we've
been doing it with this community been
super committed to it so it's kind of
nice because you can look at your bank
account and there's not a lot of charges
in there
um our budgeting has been super easy to
do but I got into our bank account the
other day and I saw a few Amazon charges
and I was like how can that be we're not
spending any money this month like what
what's going on Amazon so
I go into our account and normally this
is really sad y'all this is kind of
embarrassing to admit on air but part of
the reason for doing no spend month is
because we were going a little crazy on
Amazon like you know it's so easy to
just get a little thing here and a
little thing there and all of a sudden
you have all these Amazon transactions
so you know normally it's drag and drop
drag and drop drag and drop we you know
put it in you know Beauty category we've
got clothes we've got all these things
and occasionally there's a charge that
comes through that we don't know what it
is and you know my husband and I we
share budgeting Duty duties and it's
easy to just go okay well we'll just put
that in the miscellaneous category it's
like one charge it's 10 bucks it's five
bucks doesn't happen too often but you
know it does happen sometimes so I see
these two charges come through and I'm
like I'm racking my brain so I go to our
recent orders I'm like
thinking I'm like did my husband cheat
on no spend months like what's going on
and there's nothing in my recent orders
and I'm like okay so then I go like
digging around in Amazon and I'm like
looking for any sort of transaction and
I finally see George that we have been
signed up for Paramount plus and
Discovery Plus for 10 months like wow no
clue never open the app for 10 months
straight for 10 months straight
ouch that is so embarrassing did you
figure out what that number is it's like
well over 100 so it's ten dollars for
one charge and five dollars for the
other
ouch right so I call Amazon and I'm like
I did something stupid I'm surprised
they even picked up a real person picked
up oh it took a while I had to like go
through some form and then like they
have the automated system I just kept
being like real person real person
customer service real person and finally
someone picked up and they were like
yeah we can give you a refund we'll
we'll do one month and it was like one
month I was like can I at least have a
few months so they refunded three months
and I had seven months still of stupid
tax wow I know y'all I spent nearly a
hundred dollars that's gotta hurt in
stupid tax never open the app and I
think I guess the only thing I can
imagine is that our kids like grab the
remote at some point and try to watch
like the first episode of Yellowstone or
something no not the night was it the
new iCarly reboot oh George Paramount
plus you caught me
it's the only reason I can imagine
signing up for this thing I know yeah so
some questions will get you y'all I
promise I'm good with money but that's
real stupid
there you go so that's my stupid Tech
story but thank God for no spend month
because I'm like I woke up three years
from now and been like wait what
whatever I'm paying for what have we
been paying for so this is the strategy
of these companies right it's just like
you forget about it and it's a small
enough that you don't really fight it at
least you tried to fight back and you
got three months back I tried but I mean
I also kind of deserved it like that's
just a good reminder to me to like pay
attention to the details don't just get
lazy and be like oh well it's just one
transaction that I didn't realize what
it was there you go like I should have
been paying better attention like that
is on me and also these companies can be
kind of sneaky like there's also like
you know if you've got your smart TV or
whatever and they have like a show up
there and it looks like it's part of
your queue but sometimes when you click
on it it's like the seven day free trial
and in actuality you're signing up for
an account with that service providers
I'm like man or was just my kids last
week I signed up it was like a show time
there was a movie that's only on
Showtime so I was like great I'll sign
up for the free trial I immediately went
into my phone and canceled it and it
says cool you have 29 days left of your
trial enjoy and it was done so I think a
good life hack is to immediately cancel
it and they'll usually still give you
the remainder of your trial that's good
if you know what happened so there's no
effect oh and yeah do a little budget
audit go back into all of your bank
statements and go do we actually know
what that was for is that legit do we
still need that and you will give
yourself a raise just in doing that yeah
and that's one of the benefits of doing
a no spend month because it's like you
clear out everything and so what's left
you really have to evaluate that was one
of our goals this month is you know
since we're not spending anything and
even with groceries we're just paying
cash for groceries so it's like anything
in our account that's not supposed to be
there is going to show up so we've been
evaluating every subscription everything
that comes through our account even
things that are like somewhat needed
we're like is there a better way to get
that cheaper is there a way that we can
cut down because the goal is not just to
not spend for a month we're trying to
you know buckle down on our budget as
much as possible on all the expenses
long term I love it well thank you for
sharing and being so vulnerable You're
so brave Christina
I love it thanks George well let's get
get to the phones Angela is in Akron
Ohio Angela welcome to the Ramsay show
how's it going
how are you we are doing great how can
we help today
okay I have a question I have eighteen
thousand dollars on a HELOC loan at
currently it's like 9.2 percent okay so
when I was reviewing some other
Financial things and looking and
thinking of ideas of how to
um you know reduce this I looked into my
401k now my current rate of return is
only 4.7 so I can borrow 14
000 of that
um from my 401k is that smart for me to
do no
that would be equivalent to you having a
an arm injury and going you know what
I'm gonna break my leg to move the pain
there
to make the arm better and so we're just
robbing Peter to pay Paul and even worse
you're robbing Angela's future
with interest
what kind of friend would Angela be put
back your in when I was pulled when you
pay back your interest you're you're
paying your interest to yourself so
that's not a lot that makes no sense
then why wouldn't we all be borrowing
from our 401ks because it's a
money-making scheme I just found the
gold mine no it's got It's going to the
company you're not giving yourself
interest
you're paying the payment back into the
account but the interest you're not
gaining
that goes to the company so the lady on
the phone that said well the interest
goes back to your account she's meaning
like to their account yes there's no way
that is factual so I would not do this
401k loan for a thousand reasons I would
go ahead and attack this HELOC with a
Vengeance what did you use the HELOC for
uh I had to it was a divorce situation I
had to get out of my primary mortgage
which I was only at like three percent
so then I uh I got the HELOC and at the
time I thought that
I thought that I had signed on at five
percent fixed you know because it was a
special it was supposed to be a special
thing of the he-life well it turns out
needless to say it didn't work out that
way so now I'm just at the variable rate
so my total amount and it's on my
mortgage my actual total amount is like
33 000 so what I was gonna do is take 15
000 of that and I have an offer for zero
percent interest for like 15 months
then
you keep getting bitten by snakes and
you keep going back into a den of snakes
you don't think the only solution is to
pay off the debt there's no amount of
borrowing we can do and moving things
around from the zero percent over here
you're just gonna keep falling into
these traps well Angela I appreciate
your vulnerability because you said like
I'm frustrated for you right and you
thought you had
a not the only person like that is why
companies have skyscrapers that's why
there's people that fall into these
traps because it seems so good on the
front end yeah we need to get on a
budget sell everything you can make as
much money as you can and attack your
debts from smallest to largest using the
debt snowball method hang on the line
I'm gonna send you Financial Peace
University it'll walk you step by step
through this I'm also going to give to
you every dollar premium our budgeting
tool and these things paired hand in
hand will get you out of this mess
without having to borrow any more money
run away from all of these offers
they're not offering you anything but
lifelong payments thanks for the call
Angela this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
all right Christina so we just took a
question from Angela and she was asking
if she should borrow from her 401k to
pay off the HELOC and we of course told
her this is a a bad idea do not borrow
from your 401k for a whole bunch of
reasons but it also brought me to the
idea of the HELOC because I just saw
this article yesterday from
lifehacker.com and here's the headline
why every homeowner should have a HELOC
ready to go and so the author goes on to
explain that a hurricane had swept
through and his first floor turned into
an aquarium and so they didn't have the
money for the repairs but then he
remembered they took out a HELOC which
is a line of credit against her home
and it saved their butts and it goes on
to explain how helocs are the greatest
emergency fund and it just reminded me
that you know it's a better emergency
fund an emergency fund right with money
in the bank instead of putting your
house at risk oh and so that's exactly
what a HELOC is is it's a home equity
line of credit that's what it stands for
and along with your HELOC that you get
approved for there's transaction fees
minimum withdrawal fees inactivity fees
early termination fees required balances
and of course there's a variable
interest rate Christina oh George that's
pain and they say it's based on the
market but really it's just however they
want to screw you that month is how that
works and here's what the scary part is
when you take out a HELOC your home is
at risk because if you default you
misstep on those payments the bank can
take your home
and an emergency fund is supposed to
protect you not put you at more risk
right like this is not a safe way to go
about things this they are not your
friends they are not there to protect
people see it like well it's just
attached to my home so it's better than
going and taking on new debt oh
yikes and it's also attached to your
home your primary residence yes super
scary it does not create cash flow it's
just a giant credit card attached to
your house that can also make your house
go away because the bank can take it so
instead of the HELOC here's a better
solution
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and have good
homeowners insurance in place and check
on that homeowner's insurance every year
because as the value of your home goes
up you need to make sure the replacement
cost is also going up inside of that
homeowner's insurance that's such a good
call out and it's just a good reminder
you know to let today be the day where
you check your subscriptions you check
your insurance make sure you're up to
date on everything and have everything
you need because it's you know you don't
want to look back after something like a
hurricane or some sort of natural
disaster and think if I had just made a
phone call and adjusted things a little
bit things could be totally different
like let this be your wake-up call to
check your insurance and make sure
everything is set yeah we are seeing a
rise in people taking out these helocs
and 401K loans because they're going
well it's better than a credit card and
I can't have the credit limit that I can
with my HELOC and it's just a different
way a different trap different flavor of
the day that's holding Americans back
from Building Wealth well and it's also
kind of just a different mindset like
when Angela was talking she was like I
thought this was the golden thing but
then I got the zero percent financing
offer and what if I put it over here and
it's like or what if we just got
aggressive and paid it off and had an
emergency fund like you got to shift
your mindset to you know not just look
at these like quick fixes and these
things that involve debt like try to
actually solve the root cause like the
root issue which is getting rid of the
debt and then having an emergency fund
so that you don't go back in debt yeah
don't fall for these marketing shortcuts
these companies are offering you with
zero percent introductory offers there's
no free money out there the only way to
do this is to pay it off and we
recommend the debt snowball method list
out your balances from smallest to
largest take on the side job do the
overtime cut the expenses down to
nothing it's the only way to get the set
out of your life once and for all
and it's worth the effort it is worth
the effort for that peace of mind like
to not have to live in this
anxiety-filled game of trying to figure
out how to beg borrow and steal to keep
things moving around like you can solve
this for good amen all right let's get
to the phones Ashland awaits in
Fairbanks Alaska Ashland welcome to the
show
we are glad to have you on the line how
can we help
so I'm getting married in 17 days
that's exciting
thank you
um so my fiance and I are kind of in a
big life transition point we're both
going to graduate this spring and he's
about to go off to PhD school um he's
going to go for his best or his uh the
PG in chemistry
um and so we're looking at a bit of a
move and
um he's definitely like for his PhD
school they're going to cover at least
the first few years
but it's possible that they won't that
he won't have funding for an additional
couple years if he has to go on like a
five or six year plan
um so my question really is I'm looking
at saving up money to cover those last
couple years of his tuition if we have
to but I'm not sure what the best way to
save that money is
um he kind of wants to put it in some
kind of like real estate
um
but since we're moving and all of that I
don't want to try to invest in real
estate I'm looking at like
um just I yield savings accounts or
bonds or something like that but I don't
know what the best way to save that
money is so what's the timeline for this
are we talking two years from now you
might need to have this cash liquid
we're talking like four to five years
okay and how much are you thinking like
if if you have to pay for that last few
years What's the total cost
um that depends a lot on where we go
we've got like three very different top
schools right now
um one of them is Dartmouth one is UC
Davis and one is um University of
Colorado Boulder so it would vary a lot
um but definitely I'm thinking in the 40
to 60 000 range so are any of these
schools offering like a full ride
completely paid all the way through
um we're not entirely sure yet that's
kind of we're in the stage still of
figuring that out and that'll depend a
little bit because they'll kind of
dictate where we go but I'm thinking
that they'll offer usually usually they
offer at least four years but if you
take an additional couple years
um they often don't cover that and and
walk us through okay what would take a
couple more years like they've got the
four years of funding and what's kind of
the variables that would determine if it
takes longer
so the variables really are just like
how fast he wants to get through it um
how much he wants to put into it I mean
would he be working during this time
it would be so a lot of the PHD school
is research based um so you'd get paid a
little bit of the research or if you
took on a TA position
um he would get paid for that a little
bit
um are there employers that would fund
this if he just went into the workforce
full time are there employers that would
go hey we'll fund your PhD
I don't I don't know honestly
um
I don't know what that would what was
his purpose in getting the PHD Now
versus waiting and working a little bit
um just to continue his studies I guess
he really wants to become a professor
okay
so if I'm in your shoes like I'm doing a
lot of This research on the front end I
love that right now you're diving into
savings and we'll talk about that in a
second but you know one of the biggest
things is like diving into these details
and this ROI analysis making sure it's
going to pay off and even with the
different years like getting super
motivated on the front end to say you
know I don't want to take six years if I
got four years paid for and I'm not
working outside of this like I'm gonna
make sure I finish in four years because
that's a huge problem with undergrad
right now I think the stat is like only
40 of people graduate in four years and
it's like each of those years costs a
ton of money so I would be really
thinking wisely and even just like get
out a spreadsheet and start doing the
numbers with each school like ask those
details talk to the scholarship
department the financial aid department
ask them you know I want to know and map
out exactly how much this is going to
cost me what yours are paid for and you
know compare that before you decide on
this huge move which is so exciting
getting married in 17 days all these
cool transitions like I want to know the
numbers because and if I'm in your shoes
like that's going to make a huge that's
going to be a huge factor in deciding
where we go where we start our lives and
then just also like George said
evaluating the ROI of actually getting
the degree you know is right now the
best time to do it is there an employer
that would possibly pay for it is there
a school that you can go to completely
free because there are PHD programs that
are free all the way through so do you
guys have any debt right now
we do not okay well if I'm looking at it
on paper it looks like you have to save
10 grand a year for the next four years
just in case right I don't know that
that's worth investing you could put in
index funds if you wanted to but you're
probably just better off putting that in
a high yield savings account you can get
three or four percent right now or 529
or 529 is another great option
um to have some tax benefits as well so
good luck on the journey it sounds like
there's a lot of variables just get
through the wedding right now we can
make the other decisions later
congratulations I'm going to send you
guys Financial Peace University as a
wedding gift on us as well so hang on
the line Austin we'll get that over to
you that puts this hour of the Ramsay
show in the books my thanks to Christina
Ellis and all the folks in the booth and
you America appreciate you listening
we'll be back real soon
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to ramsesolutions.com
today to sign up for the newsletter
again that's ramseysolutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsey
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I'm your host George Campbell Join
This Hour by Christina Ellis and the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well Christine I want to kick off this
hour talking about something that so
many people are struggling with in
today's America and that is rent prices
here's an article from axios.com I'm
going to read the headline in my own way
because this is a family-friendly show
data shows the rent is still too dang
high oh yeah it says the average
American household is now considered
rent burden with a record share of
renters spending more than 30 percent of
income on rent each month this is a
painful surge for many coming coming at
a time when inflation has driven up the
cost of food and energy costs credit
card debt is rising spending is falling
and there's a shift in spending to more
necessary necessary items rather than
luxury type purchases well that's that's
good that's a good thing but rents are
sticky they are likely to climb much
further they're not they aren't likely
to go they aren't likely oh gosh thank
God that's good but don't expect them to
fall much from where they are now and of
course the surge in home prices in the
housing market has pushed this number up
and you know inflation's applying demand
a lot of factors here but at the end of
the day it's just a lot of frustrated
everyday people going like this is
insane my rent went up you know another
600 bucks and I can't do anything about
it and so we wanted to give you guys
some practical things you can do there's
no magic trick here there's no Silver
Bullet I'm not going to give you some
life hack these are all things that take
compromise sacrifice they're not fun but
it will put you in a better financial
situation yeah and and we just empathize
because we got team members here who've
had to move because it's like all of a
sudden their landlord raised their rent
or their apartment complex raised their
rent 400 600 which that's a lot even for
somebody who's budgeting who's living on
a budget and being disciplined with
their money it's it's pretty painful to
see those numbers but we do want to give
you hope because there are strategies
around that yeah I mean right here where
our headquarters is Franklin Tennessee
Williamson County I think it's the 10th
or 11th wealthiest County in the nation
and so if you work in this area it's
hard to live in this area and Dave
always jokes about when he was a kid you
know he lived on the other side of the
tracks miles away going like oh well
that's where the rich people live and
you know cost of living is a real issue
and a lot of people who live on the
coast if you live in the Bay Area or you
live in New York or Boston or New Jersey
you feel this pain when you're not
making three hundred thousand dollars as
someone who works at Google or someone
who just got laid off from Google more
likely and you're going what do I do
when I make Thirty forty fifty thousand
dollars and I still have this crazy high
rent well and some people kind of just
close their eyes and they kind of make
the the excuse that like there's no
other option or the I mean I I hesitate
to say excuse because it's like I feel
for y'all and I feel for people in this
situation but
the option is not to stick your head in
the sand and go well I gotta spend 50 of
my income on rent because it's like that
has very long-term consequences so we
want you to be super strategic and
really think through you know even
though this is crazy and the market is
crazy and it's unfortunate like what can
we do so for starters if you are single
this is especially hard for you because
you don't have you know the possibility
of dual income where you have both
spouses working which really helps cover
that rent number and so you might need
to go get a roommate and do that in a
safe way of course vet people through
Facebook communities mutual friends and
see if you can cut all of your expenses
in half by doing that I know it's not
fun if you're a grown adult to try to
get a roommate in your late 20s 30s even
40s is hard and it feels awkward but if
it cuts your expenses in half and allows
you to pay off debt and build wealth
then it's worth it for a season yeah and
another thing is to shop around so one
if you cannot be in a hurry when you
need to move that's great if you can
give yourself a little bit of Runway if
you know that your lease is going to be
up in four months or even in two months
and that your landlord May raise your
rent start thinking
and start thinking about you know are
there other places in the area and do
your research so we actually sold our
house last year and we decided we wanted
to rent for you know a bit while we
moved down here and kind of figured out
where we wanted to live and I shopped
around like crazy and I'm gonna be real
honest y'all the rent deal we found was
Bonkers but I largely think it was
because I kind of got
pretty obsessed with the like research
process and now I look at the cost and
I'm like that is actually crazy so you
know look for those Diamonds in the
Rough don't just go you know I like this
glamorous complex that has this really
cool pool the granite countertops the
hardwood floors it's been renovated that
may be out of the budget right now right
and you may get a way better deal down
the street for somewhere that's still
really great but just way more in your
budget and the other thing is go further
down the street literally further out of
the expensive areas and yes there may be
somewhat of a commute instead of a 15
minute and maybe 30 minutes but that's
worth it if you can save 400 bucks a
month and the other piece of this is a
lot of people are now working remotely
so if you're one of those people you
have the opportunity to live anywhere
let me remind you and while it's ideal
to live in downtown Manhattan it may be
more ideal financially to be further out
in Astoria George I'm hesitant for you
to say that because I'm like that means
more people are going to come to
Tennessee come on down hey they're going
to be here anyways not because oh man
our cost is an hour
you live here so we're like I'm going
further out but there are things you can
do and again none of these are like
ideal silver bullets and hopefully the
market comes back down and cools off a
little bit and we'll slowly see those
rent prices come down but for now we
also can go make more income and so if
you are making 30 and you feel like
you've been in this thing too long you
should be making more go apply for those
new jobs sharpen up the resume our
friend Ken Coleman has some great
resources at his website Ken coleman.com
to help you with that but if you can
make 50 instead of 30 well that changes
the numbers now and we can breathe
and lastly getting out of debt will help
you breathe when it comes to affording
your rent one of the reasons rent feels
so crazily high is because you also have
700 800 in payments on this side because
of your student loans your car payments
the credit card payments the personal
loans it all adds up well and just
really making sure that you're buckling
down on your budget like I've we're
pretty intense with our budget but we've
been doing this no spend month and it's
been crazy looking at the numbers of how
much we saved like we thought we were
pretty tight on our budget and at the
end of the month we are saving so much
money like we thought we couldn't eat on
100 a week and we did it and we found
all these other ways to save so it's
like even if you are on a budget like
really evaluate it deeply and see if
there's anywhere else you can cut so
that you have a little bit of breathing
room and that's a great reminder
Christina our parameters as far as rent
or mortgage goes is no more than 25 of
your after-tax income and so that if
that's you and you're doing the numbers
you're going my rent is 1500 bucks and I
take home three grand well that's fifty
percent of your income being eaten up
it's going to be hard to live and to
build wealth and to save and to pay off
that debt and to put food on the table
to put eggs on the table when that much
of your life is being eaten up by the
rent and so it you've we've got to find
a solution and go all right we need a
roommate we need to move further out and
we need to get on a budget and so you
can jump onto every dollar that's our
budgeting tool you can use it for free
and start to Crunch these numbers and
figure out where we can shave some
expenses how can we figure out how to
afford the expenses we really need and
figure out what the needs are versus the
wants and we want the nice apartment but
that might be down the line once we're
out of debt and we increase our income
and maybe one day we won't have that
pesky roommate leaving the dishes in the
sink that's a tough one for me Christina
now that is I'm glad I have a roommate
now and it's my wife best roommate I've
ever had
gosh no more dudes just the dudes get it
together guys oh my gosh all right more
of your calls coming up triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com
Ramsey today and set up a free product
tour that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you know paying off debt is smart saving
and investing is smart but there's one
key to winning with money that people
Overlook all the time and that is
protecting your finances from
emergencies and that is where insurance
comes into play now there are 10 types
of insurance that you might need based
on what your life looks like today and
lucky for you we've built a tool called
the coverage checkup to show you exactly
which types you need to add to drop and
to adjust we'll even rank your coverage
list by importance email it to you and
connect you with the Ramsay trusted
insurance providers so you can get your
plan in place fast seriously this could
be the most important five minutes you
spend today a friend of ours Donald H
wrote in and I like how he puts it for
anyone who has not completed this
checkup do it now you never know when
something will happen and you never want
to leave your family in a bad situation
so this is totally free just go to
ramseysolutions.com checkup that's
ramseysolutions.com
checkup do not let an emergency sneak up
on you protect your family now all right
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Debbie joins us
up next in Anchorage Alaska Debbie
welcome to the show
call absolutely what's going on
um I recently received a 200 000
settlement check and we are trying to
decide what is the best use of the fund
if it would be better to pay
um one of our loans off on our vacation
rental home or if it's better to invest
it or what you would recommend all right
what was the settlement from
um I was a bfo of an organization and I
discovered a lot of thought and then an
embezzlement and through the process
um I received the check wow wow well I'm
usually it's you were in a terrible
accident so as far as how settlements go
you got it that's one of the better ones
I've heard
yeah yeah okay it turns out okay but it
sounds like it was a nasty situation
so it was a tough few years yeah well
I'm glad you're past it and is that
money already in the bank
yes it is ah I bet you're breathing a
lot easier now
so where where are you guys at
financially how much money did you
already have in the bank
um we have a comfortable amount of
basins in our bank account and we have
no debt except for our
um Second Home which we use
um for a vacation home or a rental home
when we're not there so we have no
your primary residence is paid for
what's left on this vacation property on
the mortgage
on 500 000
um 150
000 with some considering paying off is
um a home equity line of credit
um to the other part of the mortgage so
total owed outstanding is 550 000. okay
yeah I would that would be the next step
is to pay that down so unless there's
other things you had planned expenses
for like maintenance repairs a roof the
HVAC upgrading a car I would throw this
at that I would not invest the money and
you all have a fully funded emergency
fund correct
yeah and you're investing toward
retirement
yes I do have invest on retirement
accounts through employers yeah are you
guys doing 15 into those accounts
no what's the amount currently
um whatever's equally matched you
roughly about three percent are you
doing any investing beyond that
no I think that's where we need some
help ah so I don't better to use the 200
000 for investment or maybe another
rental property
um you know more
um land what's your household income
um roughly a hundred thousand okay and
how old are y'all
um I'm
almost
um in this deceased my husband's retired
okay so he's not working does he have
any source of income
um minimal um no yeah so it's basically
all on you and you're making 100K and we
want to retire with dignity someday
yes but then in addition we have the
rent total income but you know that
nothing you can guarantee you know I
just want to say I'm glad I'm not the
only one that takes a few seconds to
think about how old she is what do I
want to say here carry the three that's
me now
so Debbie here's what I would do if I'm
in your shoes I'm going to increase my
investing to 15 in my you said it's a
401k
yeah okay is there I would I would put
15 in that 401k do you have you can also
use a Roth IRA and so here's the order
you would do this in take the match what
you're already doing
beyond that we can max out a Roth IRA
for the year
which uh for you in your 50s I believe
there's a thousand dollar catch-up
contribution so you might be able to put
a think 7 500 in there for the year
so you could Max that out and then go
back to the 401K and finish out the 15
which for you would be fifteen thousand
dollars total from your income
okay and then any money beyond that
let's start attacking this vacation
property and get this thing paid for
how does that feel do you feel like you
have margin in your budget to start
increasing your Investments
yes yes we do okay how often are you
guys at the vacation property
um we try to do
um like three four months a year the
rest of the
um year rented out okay and is that
roiing well is it what's the net profit
per year on that
after all expenses maintenance mortgage
all that
roughly 75 000. okay
well I would use all the profit and try
to get this thing paid off before you
guys retire and once you have this thing
paid off let's max out all the
retirement we can so that you don't have
to work for another 15 20 years
okay that would be the goal so I'm using
most of this settlement to pay down the
mortgage outside of maxing out the Roth
IRA for the year and let's bump up your
investment contributions to 15 so that
we can ratchet up that compound interest
growth over the next decade
I urge you to go to ramsaysolutions.com
retirement state
it's really
calculators I think a lot of people
50s it's not worth trying to save for
retirement and they feel scared that
they can't get there but when you get
those calculators and you see how much
how much you can save in 20 years how
powerful compound interest is and that
you really can hit an amazing spot
within 20 years it's exciting so I want
you to you know do that so you can get
excited around this and this is
something where you're like okay we're
going to attack this because in 20 years
we wouldn't be baby step millionaires
with paid off houses and you know your
primary residence and the second one I
think you can get really excited around
it oh yeah and I you know I'm inspired I
just met a a nice gentleman out there in
the lobby we go out during the breaks
and he let us know casually he's a baby
steps millionaire with two paid off
properties his primary residence and now
a vacation home in Florida and he's
riding Sky High no payments in the world
and he's been doing this plan he told us
for 15 years really focused on it I'm
sure he still had a good head on his
shoulders before that to get to that
point and set him up for success but you
can do this and a lot of people
Christina they go like well it's too
late for me I didn't know this this
stuff when I was 20 and so I'm now in my
50s and what's the point I'm not going
to make that much progress you would be
shocked at how much progress you can
make in five to ten years and a lot of
people in their 50s they're making the
most money they've made in their careers
right so it's a great time to finally
get rid of that debt have that emergency
fund in place and begin maxing out their
retirement contributions absolutely it's
a great time and that's why it's just so
exciting to see the numbers because yeah
I think a lot of people just write
themselves off they feel hopeless
they're like it's too late but it's like
when you see the numbers and you see how
it works it feels like magic you're like
wait really like if I only save this
much money I can be here in 20 years Wow
Let's go one baby step millionaire that
term feels like well that's not I'll
never be that but when you think about
what a millionaire is it's just having a
net worth of a million dollars so what
you own minus what you owe your assets
minus liability so if you have a paid
for home that's worth 500 000 and you
have five hundred thousand dollars
sitting in 401k and IRAs You by
definition are a millionaire you don't
need to make a million dollars a year in
fact the top three careers that we found
in our millionaire study were engineer
accountants and teachers
people who for sure don't make a million
dollars a year and the reason is they're
process driven people they've got a good
head on their shoulders they're not
trying to impress people with luxury
cars and mansions they're just going to
work every day and putting money away
into those retirement accounts and over
a long period of time that money grows
thanks to compound interest and all of a
sudden you wake up one day and you go oh
my gosh we can do what we want yes we
can work because we want to not because
we have to that's the kind of decisions
I want to be able to make as I get older
and that's what you can do when you
follow this Ramsay plan this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 off everything site-wide
go to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis this
hour open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five our question
of the day comes from Rebecca in
Oklahoma she writes in and here's her
question my boyfriend and I plan to get
married after graduating in May with our
degrees in physical therapy we
anticipate starting salaries of 60 to 70
000. our only debts will be our student
loans 115 000 for him 137 000 for me
we've started discussing money
particularly paying off student loans
and want to get started on the right
foot we already have our emergency fund
saved so we'll be starting on step two
when we graduate we know you guys
recommend staying away from income
driven repayment plans and to use the
debt snowball method instead if we're
using the snowball we should be paying
off his first should we work at paying
mine off at the same time or is there a
better way to knock out this debt
so the first thing that stands out to me
is how she says our only debts are
around 250 000. that's a lot of loans
whoa like the worst casually huh like
makes me sick to my stomach for them
that is that's a lot and I mean she's
got an emergency fund saved so I mean
that's we don't know if that's the
starter of a thousand or if they went
then skip to step three and have a fully
funded emergency fund I'm gonna assume
it's the one thousand dollar starter
well the first thing I'm gonna say is
like let's level set this is not only
air quotes two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in debt this is a
quarter of a million dollars right this
is a big deal you make 60. yeah you're
starting off you're married life with
250 000 in student loans this is a big
deal like we need to attack it like it's
a big deal so here's what I'm seeing if
the numbers are adding up they should be
making combined a household income of
120 to 140 000 and they have total
student loan debt of 252 000. so if
you're using the debt snowball method
most student loan balances they're of
that size and magnitude are probably
broken out into smaller loans so I
wouldn't see it as we're going to pay
off his first than mine I would just
break it out by each individual student
loan and each individual balance line
those up from smallest to largest
regardless of what the interest rates
are and attack the little one first make
minimum payments on the rest and as you
do that you'll knock them out faster
you're going to free up the payments
you're going to feel the progress you're
going to stay motivated along the way
you can use visual trackers to you know
stay excited about this celebrate every
little Milestone and it's going to take
a while hopefully your incomes continue
to go up
physical therapists can make great money
so my hope is that they can each make
six figures and they knock this debt out
within the next I'm gonna give them a
timeline of four years I think they
could do this well I think if you have
that mindset shift where you start going
this is a lot of money and this makes me
uncomfortable and I want to get rid of
it like you can pick up extra jobs you
know you can see if you can take every
overtime shift possible for your
physical therapy job like do anything
you can to get this paid off quickly but
first you got to realize this is a
problem like don't say it's only 250 000
if not we'll get to it when we get to it
right this is our full-time job is
getting rid of this debt and the good
news is that you're you're young you're
getting married after graduation this is
the time in life where you have time to
work those extra jobs you don't have
kids yet like get this out of the way so
that you're free moving forward attack
it scorched Earth with aggression so
that it's gone and then you have the
rest of your married life ahead free
from all of this and if you want to get
a aggressive at this and you can get
that income up you know you could do
this in three years think about it this
way if you could throw eighty four
thousand dollars at these student loans
every year which if you're making 140 is
possible if you're making 150 160 170
it's even more possible then we can
knock this out
in three years that's exciting 36 months
this can be out of your life and so
don't wait on forgiveness don't wait on
the White House let's get about the
business of getting rid of Sallie Mae's
prison that she's put us in well George
this just gets me so fired up like this
topic in general the fact that there are
students graduating from college saying
that they only have two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in student loan
debt that is a toxic system that has
taught kids that 250 000 in student
loans no big deal that everybody takes
them out that they're necessary it's a
rite of passage we all just take out
debt to get these degrees we're not even
sure what we're going to do with the
degrees but let's take out the loans to
get them it's so frustrating which is
why we've got our documentary borrowed
future which is exposing that toxic
system massive student loan crisis 45
million Americans are in debt because of
their education and how did we get here
well we do the full expose in our
award-winning documentary Bard future
uncovering this dark side of the student
loan industry and what's cool Christina
is it's always been available you know
on Amazon Amazon Prime video we put it
on YouTube earlier this year which is
exciting but now for the first time ever
it's available on Fox Nation so uh you
know you can find shows documentaries
and movies there that celebrate in
America and this is a different kind of
celebration of America this is
celebrating what we could be if we got
out of this toxic student loan crisis
that we're in and here's what's crazy
the average is now 38 792 dollars for
graduates in student loan debt and
Christina Ellis is featured in that
documentary as well as Dave Ramsey Dr
John deloney a bunch of Industry
insiders uh micro Mark Cuban lots of
thought leaders weigh in on this epic
failure of the Student Loan program and
expose how the system is built to work
against you and it's like parents
and watch this documentary especially if
they're in high school if they're about
to walk towards this Cliff sit down with
them have this conversation talk about
money even if it's weird even if it's
uncomfortable even if they don't really
want to hear it have the conversation
and the great thing about a documentary
is it's not like we're gonna sit down
and have this boring conversation about
money you can say hey can we watch a
movie together this weekend yes it feels
more like a movie it's very exciting
yeah thrilling twists and turns but it
can save them from so much in the long
run it can really shift their mindset
and help them go to school debt free
absolutely so tune in to Borrowed future
on Amazon Prime video YouTube and now
Fox Nation love it let's get to the
phones Jasmine awaits in Long Island
Jasmine welcome to the show
hi thank you guys for having me sure
what's your question
um my boyfriend and I are about to turn
four years and and we have been talking
about marriage for a little bit I
graduate next year he's currently not in
school
and we're we're both tackling
individually our own debt I should be
done in the next six months he should be
done paying off his car which is the
only thing that he has
um by the end of the year
but um we I just don't really know kind
of where we should be at financially
individually or even together
um
um before we actually get married
because I know there's a lot of a lot of
things to save up for you know like the
wedding or the apartment or if he wants
a house like so he does say that he
wants a house but it doesn't have to be
very expensive or a big house but he
does want to live in a home
um I I we discussed that I told him did
we discuss that later on but I just
don't know where we should really be at
financially because I want our marriage
to start successful
love it when you all talk about money
how do those conversations go do you
feel like you're pretty much on the same
page or what do they look like
yeah I mean in the beginning it was a
very long like it was a while for me I
was always a spender I did not listen to
the rainbow show I was very much always
I had the most debt and I worked to pay
that off and he's helped me kind of
motivate me to get me there and now
we're finally both on the same page so I
started from Institute university he has
not whoa he's still kind of like oh
what's he doing does he not want to
marry Jasmine
if he knows this is important to you he
should be doing it
yeah I've been I've been telling him so
hopefully I he's very close to actually
doing it but we've both come a long way
in terms of
how we're on the same page about
finances okay well there's no particular
way that you have to be this way before
you're married the best thing you can do
is to be completely debt free with a
fully funded emergency fund and pay cash
for the wedding do not go into debt for
the wedding do it on a strict budget
weddings can get out of control of
course he's gonna have to save up and
get that engagement ring and I would not
be jumping into Home Ownership anytime
soon you guys need to rent for a year
somewhere start saving up that down
payment if you're going to stay in Long
Island it's freaking expensive isn't it
yes it is and that's my worry it might
be a longer Journey or we decide we're
going to move further away and uh either
way it's going to take a little while to
save that down payment don't let him
rush into this because he thinks he's a
fancy man now because he's a married man
and you got to have a home that's a
bunch of bullcrap so go slow both of you
becoming debt free with a fully funded
emergency fund cash flowing the wedding
that is the best thing you can do and I
hope he goes to Financial Peace
University with you otherwise we're
gonna have some hard conversations with
this guy thanks for the call
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I know lots of you out there you've
got some goals to improve your money
improve your career improve your
relationships this year and if you want
a proven plan to crush the debt and
build wealth you can do that with Dave's
best-selling book The Total Money
Makeover and learn the seven baby steps
to guide you along your money journey
and if every day feels like a Monday for
you and you're not happy with where
you're at in your career it's time to
change that and you can do that with Ken
Coleman's get clear career assessment
and learn exactly what you were created
to do and what careers fit you best and
of course if you want to deepen your
relay relationship with your spouse your
kids your friends your family you can
pick up John deloney's questions for
humans decks which are super fun and a
great way to build those connections
build those relationships get all of
those books and tools that will take
your goals to the next level order them
today at ramseysolutions.com store
all right Karen joins us up next in Salt
Lake City Karen welcome to the show
hi thank you sure my husband and I are
working on the plan and
um so we plan to have all of our debt
paid off by the end of the year awesome
we have a very clear plan of how much we
want to save in the next five years and
that in the next or in about five years
we would like to move and to buy a home
and that's where it kind of gets tricky
for us
we hear a lot of examples on the show of
people paying off their homes that cost
you know a hundred thousand to four
hundred thousand dollars and for us
that's kind of like laughable because we
don't live in those kind of states
um over where we live or where we would
love to live which is Colorado to get a
decent quality home with maybe four
bedrooms for a family of five we would
need at least about five hundred
thousand dollars
um and to be able to do that on on
Ramsey's plan
um what we've kind of tried to calculate
is to have the 15-year mortgage 25 of
our income we would really need to be
making at least two hundred thousand a
year which is yeah I mean double what we
make now so you guys make a hundred
uh so my husband makes about 80 and then
next month I'll be opening a daycare at
our home here and I'll be making about
50. okay so that'll put you about 130.
and are are y'all homeowners right now
we do we own a condo in Utah
and how much do you have left on that
so we just moved in here
um so we still have 360. that was um it
sounds like a ton so it's brand new we
just moved in like six months ago here
in Utah
like the cheapest thing you could get
with three bedrooms and two baths is
like 300 to 400 000 so that's kind of
why we what's the house
that's what it's worth because we just
got it so well I guess it's more worth
like 380. maybe how much did you put
down
um about 17
000 okay
so let's say it's worth 380 let's you
get a little bit of equity in there but
you're saying five years from now you
definitely want to move to Colorado and
the how the home will probably cost 500
000 that you're wanting
yes unfortunately yeah that's kind of
the market out there okay well I'm for
some reason I'm more optimistic than you
Karen I don't know why but I think we
can do this thing it's just going to
take more down payment
so it's not that you need to have more
income uh I would love that for you guys
and I think you'll get there five years
from now you hopefully are making more
than you are today
so how much debt do you have some of the
issue
issues
um we've got about 30 which like I said
will be done with by the end of the year
this year okay and then we need the
fully funded emergency fund so that'll
take a few more months after that
yes so um we decided that we would be
comfortable with 25 000 especially
living in a higher um cost State okay
for our emergency fund um so we plan on
having that done next year I mean making
1 30 I think you guys can pay off 30 and
save up 20.
in the next 12 months
and with this new daycare do you
anticipate your income increasing
significantly
no so that will be my income with the
daycare okay so right now I'm just a
stay-at-home parent um but I decided you
know I want to make money I want to do
something other than just staying home
but I do want to raise my own kids in
those years before they go to school and
so I decided decided that starting my
own daycare at home gives me both of
those opportunities and how old are your
kids right now
so right now I just have one and he is
one and a half
I'm taking your husband probably works
like a standard nine to five is that
correct
um yes
yes so the the issue that we face I
think that makes this a little unique is
when we do move he will lose his job
um because it's it's just based here
um so what we're struggling with is kind
of
um either deciding do we need to move to
a different state where a lower income
is livable or how can we like find a
different kind of job that he would like
to do what does he do right now
so he flips home he's a realtor he works
with a partner and they flip homes here
but they couldn't do that in Colorado
so kind of but his partner lives here
and his partner is the one that pays his
salary
um so it's really based on how things go
and how the market is in Colorado by the
time we move whether or not his partner
wants to keep paying his salary and
wants to flip out there
yeah that feels like a lot of risk to
put on the table could he just be a
realtor in Colorado
or do that on his own um
he could try to just be a regular
realtor
um
that's one of our options
um but we understand the that it we will
have to change jobs or that's what we're
kind of struggling with right now is how
do we find a job that pays enough to
live there
um or do we just not live there well I
feel like there's a lot of heaviness in
your voice right now and I actually see
your situation and I'm going to do the
sky's the limit you have so much ahead
of you you've got time so if he's
looking at a career change in five years
he can figure out you know what is the
ideal career that I want and then start
working backwards and saying what kind
of training do I need and and do it now
so that in five years he's qualified for
a great job the fact that he's got home
flipping experience when you get out to
Colorado and you're trying to buy a
house maybe next time you could buy a
house that's a little bit cheaper and
then do some Fixer-Upper work you know
to increase the equity pretty quickly I
mean just hearing your story and hearing
what's surrounding these decisions I
think you've got a lot of upside a lot
of great opportunity
okay what's your take-home pay Karen if
you're making that 130 what do you think
you'd take home after taxes
so like I said I haven't started the
daycare yet okay and that'll be about
next month
um that I'll open that after
um for me after taxes it'll probably be
about 40 000 take home from me okay and
then for my husband he takes home
about 65. okay so we're talking you know
8 500 bucks a month coming in and so
that means we need to get your mortgage
to around you know twenty one hundred
dollars and So based on my math if you
guys could put 300 down on that 500 home
in Colorado five years from now we can
do this and here's what that looks like
you said a year from now you're debt
free with an emergency fund that means
for the next four years after that we
can begin paying down this house house
while investing 15 and if you do you
know 50 000 a year onto that mortgage
you'll have what 150-ish left on the
mortgage and the home will probably be
worth 450 by then right
um possibly you know the Market's all
over the place right now so we're hoping
that it continues to go up yeah but if
we just use those rough numbers for
rough appreciation you owe 150 you have
the ho the home is worth 450. you sell
that you've got about 300 000 in equity
to put down on that house and that's if
your income stays at 130 for the next
five years
and so you absolutely can do this
Karen do you want to move
yes we both want to get out of here we
know for sure we are not going to live
in Utah in five years we want to be in
Colorado
um the thing that's hard as far as is
trying to figure out can we make it in
Colorado I have a plan I mean we showed
you on paper now you just got to believe
it and I think a lot of it is just the
weight of this and it just feels heavy
but I'm telling you when you start to
feel the progress getting debt free get
the emergency fund start paying the
house down and then look at on paper in
your budget you're gonna be like oh my
gosh we can do this when we see people
pay off 500 000 homes all the time like
it is very common even just around here
in Tennessee Like Houses that's that's
how much they cost and people do it you
can do it that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books
foreign
hey it's Christina Ellis if you love the
show and want to dive deeper on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host George Campbell
Join This Hour by best-selling author
Christina Ellis and it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you need some help you're at a
Crossroads you need a second or third
opinion maybe you just need some
confidence that what you're doing is the
right thing maybe you need someone to
talk you off the ledge of a terrible
decision that's one of my favorite
things to do is to help you avoid some
stupid tax we are here for you America
and Carl is kicking us kicking us off in
Washington D.C Carl welcome to the show
how you doing
I'm doing great thank you awesome how
can we help today
well I have a question I'm working on
paying off my house right now and uh one
of the things I was considering doing I
have
um on my credit card a little bit over 2
million points so somewhere around 23
000 that I could get cash
they can send me a check so I was
thinking about yeah I was thinking about
cashing that in and then putting that
towards the principal in my house so you
know what do you guys think about that I
think it's a great plan I mean if you
already have the points what did it take
you to get two million points I'm just
curious
it took me a long time is this a
lifetime of credit card spending to get
two million points
um probably about I don't know 15 years
or something like that wow do you have
any debt right now other than the house
uh uh not really not really uh-oh what
do you mean not really Carl you can't
leave us hanging out I don't have a
credit card that I pay off every month
okay and um and uh Allen that's about it
okay
so uh what does this conversion look
like to dollars is there any
23. sorry Speak directly into your phone
Carl we're having a hard time hearing
again yes no problem about twenty three
thousand dollars twenty two thousand
something in that range absolutely
what's left on the mortgage
uh 426 000.
and do you have a fully funded emergency
fund
yes okay yeah what's your household
income
um it's definitely it's the six figures
it's it's not bad it's six years okay so
you're making over a hundred thousand
what's your goal for paying off this
mortgage how many more years
I want to tell you those in five years
love it so that means we need to go
start attacking this thing I mean that's
most of your income going forward so I
pay every month extra so I put you know
I'm starting to put a thousand dollars a
month actually on the on the principle
um and any extra money I get my plan is
just completed on the house
cool well I would definitely I would
cash out of all those points on I mean
truthfully I would stop playing their
game I think you can do way better just
saving this money yourself putting it a
high yield savings account at four
percent and using that money to pay off
the mortgage or just using every future
paycheck and throwing at it as soon as
you get it
what you're saying take uh take the
money from the credit card and put it on
how you'll save the account for you I'm
saying use the cash out on the credit
card points but going forward I would
just use your income instead of playing
the credit card game have you ever
thought about what what the difference
would be if you just cut up the cards
and went hey how much could Carl put
onto this mortgage without trying to
rack up the points to eventually use 15
years down the line
yes yes yes no you're absolutely right
the only thing is the only reason why
the only thing I use my credit card is I
actually pay them off every month so
it's never really like I'm paying
interest on the credit card but what are
you using the credit card for
business
okay are you a business owner are you
self-employed yes yes yes I am
so what kind of expenses are you putting
on the card
anything all the expenses
as much as I can through my business
I'll put on the card and are you
budgeting pretty well with your business
oh yeah
okay yeah we budget we budget very well
yes hey Carl I'm wondering how's your
retirement savings looking
um
well I'm kind of starting over so uh my
retirement right now is is fully flunked
as I can get it at this point what are
you using for a retirement account
um well I have my my retirement plan
speak directly over the phone Carl sorry
we're losing you again
you have no problem I have a retirement
plan for work
and then I have my regular brokerage
account and then I have
um yeah my 401k and how much do you have
total saved right now
um
I write an essay but I'm I I know it
sounds crazy but it's
um are you a millionaire it's not enough
for reach out it's not no no it's not
enough for me to retire though I still
got a lot to go okay and I can only put
so much so I have to everything I can
put right now I can only put like in a
brokerage account because I don't
qualify for Roth IRA have you looked
into solo 401k or a SEP IRA
I mean listen to those because those
have higher contribution limits that
could help you catch up quickly if
you're self-employed and right so I
think the issue is really the way my
structure is set up I really can't do
that
okay I might still get in touch with a
smartvester pro Carl at our website
ramseysolutions.com they can walk you
through what your retirement options are
the key here is I want you taking
advantage of tax advantage accounts
first before using the brokerage account
um so that you can have the most money
as possible in retirement and part of
that plan is awesome you're wanting a
paid for house and by my math if you can
put 85k a year towards that mortgage
you'll have this thing paid off and that
23k is only going to help speed that
along but I just challenge you I just
wonder if you cut up the card and you
just used a debit card for your business
for your personal how much more progress
you could be making this is a test if
you're willing to do it call me back and
let me know how it went I had just have
a dark curiosity well and Carl hang on
the line we're going to give to you
Financial Peace University because
because you said with retirement savings
you're not where you want to be you need
a new plan so this is that plan and part
of that plan is cutting up the credit
cards a lot of times when we're spending
on cards it's you spend more money and
you're not as tight in the budget and I
know you said you're great with a budget
but I just challenge you to try out the
plan like George said give it a shot see
if it works you said you're starting
fresh that's the best time to kind of go
hey you know what let's try something
new let's try something different so
hang on the line awesome we'll get that
for you and I did some fun math for Carl
uh he said he's got two million credit
card points which in my mind I'm like
that feels like you're you're a rich
person and he said it took 15 years of
spending to get that twenty three
thousand dollars in cash that's 1500
bucks a year now I don't know about you
but I think most people especially
business owners could save up more than
1500 a year and pay themselves that cash
back with intentional spending being on
a budget being diligent and so that is
my challenge to all of you out there add
up how much you actually got not points
what does that actually amount to not a
trip to Boise what is the dollar amount
you're actually getting for all the
spending and playing the credit card
company's game and going it's five
percent of restaurants this month so I'm
gonna go eat out more uh that doesn't
make sense chief
that's not actually making you any money
you're spending more and they like that
and so that is my challenge to all of
you cut up the card for six months just
use your debit card and then call the
show and let us know your findings maybe
I'm wrong it's a good word I'm happy to
be proven wrong but I just really want
to know what it's like when you spend
your money and how you make decisions
differently due to that more of your
calls coming up AAA
825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show hey if
you're a new listener and you want to
dive deeper into the Ramsay plan and the
baby steps we've created a great tool
for you at ramseysolutions.com just
click on the get started button and
we'll help you figure out the best next
step for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today just go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on get
started
all right Christina so you people may
have heard about this in the news it's
the secure 2.0 bill
and there's some interesting things in
there and we're going to keep covering
those things on the show to update you
all on what's included but here's an
interesting one uh that has to do with
student loans and investing Biden's new
retirement law means you may not have to
choose between paying off student debt
and saving for the future it says Biden
recently signed into law a new package
of retirement Provisions one will allow
employers to match workers student loan
payments in the form of retirement plan
contributions it's a boon for those who
owe student debt said the director of
TIAA it's the recently passed secure 2.0
bill which adds a set of Provisions to
an original retirement package
implemented under the secure Act of 2019
amongst other changes the law provides
workers with more retirement saving
options and at the same time
incentivizes workers to re-enter the
workforce amid a persistent structural
labor shortage so they're trying to lure
in these young folks who who maybe
aren't in the workforce or they jumped
out and saying hey beginning in 2024
employee employers can match student
loan payments with a matching
contribution to that 401k and they're
doing this to attract those young people
who have a whole bunch of student loan
debt and uh you know it's another one of
these benefits they're trying to use to
attract them so it's very interesting so
here's the example let's say I have 450
in monthly student loan payments and I'm
I got to make these payments but I also
want to invest for the future the
employer can put 450 into my 401k as a
match
for me while I make my 450 student loan
payment
very interesting I have I think what
stands out to me I have so many
questions about if this is supposed to
bring workers back into the job market
how are they paying their student loan
debt well they weren't working that's
well it's on pause Christina so they're
all like We're Riding High yeah but
that's not gonna last forever well in
their minds it is oh they're hoping by
the time it's forgiven and we never have
to deal with it but uh you know I've got
I've got a lot of thoughts about this
but one is the frustration I would feel
if you have other payments in your life
or you've paid off your student loans
and all of a sudden your co-worker next
to you who went into a hundred thousand
dollars for his degree is all of a
sudden getting free money in his 401k
because of his decision he made to go
into debt oof that feels frustrating I
get that I empathize with those who are
struggling with student loan payments
going well I also want to retire with
dignity
but I also think it incentivizes people
to hang on to their student loan
payments if they're getting this free
Match from their employer or as they
continue to make payments yeah or even
take out more student loans maybe go
back to grad school because they know
that they're still going to be able to
that's the life hack oh gosh no I'm not
encouraging the dollars into student
loan debt so you can get a free Match
Into the 401K from here oh gosh no I
have mixed feelings though because it's
like on one hand we want people to win
with money of course like if people do
unfortunately have student loan debt
like I want them to be able to still
build up retirement savings but you're
also right in that like what are the
long-term implications and is it
ethically correct right you know what
I'd rather I want to see this debt gone
and I think a better incentive would be
for employers to match the payment to
help them pay off the debt yes now
there's enough reach breach I should run
for Congress hey if George Santos can
make it I feel like I've got a shot at
this point you know I don't think I can
make up as many lies if I wanted to as
him so wow well interesting stuff
there's a lot of interesting retirement
pieces that are actually beneficial for
folks who are trying to build wealth in
this new secure 2.0 bill so we're going
to keep you guys posted on that but just
wanted to update you on that interesting
uh student debt slash investing I'm
curious to see how this plays out and
just kind of the emotions there's
already so many emotions around
everything student loans right now but
very emotional I'm sure there will be
debates around this we'll be along for
the ride we're here for it all right
let's get to the phones Joe is in
Wisconsin Joe welcome to the show
well thank you and thank you for taking
my call sure
well I just need some advice on if I
should pay my truck off so that I could
pay my house off whoa instead of paying
it off over I think I could have it paid
off but I
February of next year what's left on the
truck loan
uh six thousand
and what's it worth
about 48. wow and what's left on the
mortgage
37. oh my goodness this is no joke
there we go so you would make a profit
of 42 000 selling the truck pay off the
mortgage and still have five thousand
dollars left over
yeah and I only drive like
maybe a mile and a half to my job
oh I don't need like you know I bought
the trucks I thought I needed it for my
house because I always need like a truck
to pick up certain things and you know
we have crazy winners here but not worth
it to thus far into seeing if it's worth
it to do this that's incredible the
truck paid off actually by the middle of
March
and then the house would be paid off by
next year early well Joe do you have any
reservations like what would keep you
from making this decision
um part of it is
um I do want to just get the house cut
off because I do drive a LCL job and
because of the crazy winter we've had we
get a lot of shorter paychecks
what's your mortgage plan
uh 643
so you'd free that up every single month
and then what's your income
uh my combined income for the household
between my two jobs
and my wife's disability on last year's
taxes was 141. awesome
man well you're gonna get you know seven
to eight thousand dollars back in your
life every year by getting rid of this
house payment and you're already making
a great income so uh and it doesn't
sound like you're like in love with a
truck it doesn't sound like you're super
attached to it
is I mean it's a nice truck I mean do
you have any other deck yeah it's only
got 17 000 miles on that's a 21
Silverado
I'd sell it
what other debt do you have all right
none I just had this truck in the house
and that's it oh my goodness man it's
just such a simpler life I just love
that you could be debt free today no
payments in the world making 141 have an
extra eight grand back in your life
every year and by the way if you want a
truck in the future you can just go pay
cash for a truck in the future
right now my truck came into 800 because
I you know I'm still paying and I still
got uh oh wow so you'd free up 800 bucks
on top of the 643. well that's like 1250
dollars you just gave yourself a raise
yeah and if I work full time with no
shortened days like I can take all my
payments in like one and a half checks
and I get paid weekly I love this plan
it's exciting
yeah I think you go get debt free and
you just gave yourself a fifteen
thousand dollar raise by doing this one
move
how does that feel well
that's good because then you know I can
start putting retirement back into my
retirement well that puts you a baby
step seven I would start maxing out
every single retirement account I can do
you have a 401k through work
I do right now before I started this I
got about a quarter of a million in
retirement and I have 19 years in the
military so at the end of this year I'll
have a pension as well awesome
wow and do you have a Roth option
through your employer for the 401K
I do Cole how old are you
I'll be 50 in about a month and a half
okay
Joe this is awesome I this is a great
place to be yeah this is exciting this
is not only are you going to be able to
get debt free this week but I see a
great trajectory ahead where it's like
you're going to be able to save
aggressively with that income with a
pension from the military you're heading
towards a pretty good retirement now
you're going to need a different car
you'll have 5 000 left do you have any
other money in the bank you could use
towards a car
no because I've been just putting
everything on the truck uh because that
truck was quite expensive so I wanted to
pay it off as soon as I could I was just
pounding it all onto the truck
do you have an emergency land
not right now that's what I would get
because I only have a thousand dollars
in savings and I have 2500 in my
checking account because all my payments
coming come out on the first then I'm
gonna pause I'm gonna keep saving until
I have enough in the bank to buy a used
car
um so that you're in a good spot and
then once this is all done let's save up
a fully funded emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and then We're
Off to the Races back to investing and
man what a wild Journey Joe this is
incredible
baby step seven just like that get rid
of the truck oh my goodness so thanks
for the call man this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the day Proverbs 1 5 a
wise man will hear an increase in
learning and a man of understanding will
acquire wise counsel
Sydney Sheldon once said libraries store
the energy that fuels the imagination
they open up Windows to the world and
Inspire us to explore and Achieve and
contribute to improving our quality of
life
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis and a
lot of people out there think Building
Wealth in this economy is impossible but
that is lies from Hope Stealers and
headlines out there you don't need to
panic you don't need to start raising
your own chickens to do this thing what
you need is a plan for your money and
that's why we're heading out on the
Building Wealth live tour where we'll
give you a proven plan to build wealth
and keep it we'll be in Indianapolis on
February the 16th Austin Texas February
the 23rd will be in Salt Lake City on
April the 24th and rounding it out in
Anaheim California on May 2nd tickets
start at just 49 bucks or you can get a
four pack of tickets for 175 bring some
friends some family it's going to be a
blast go to ramsesolutions.com events to
reserve your seats for Building Wealth
live
so excited all right Christina we need
an update on your no spend month a lot
of people out there you know like we're
it's crunch time we're in the last week
of January yes and a lot of people maybe
they've fallen off the wagon maybe they
need a little Pip in their step where
are we at well we've made it to the last
week and I put out a poll on Instagram
last night and I actually have a lot of
people in the community that are still
doing it good yes we've almost made it
y'all we're almost to the finish line
and what's super exciting to me is we
have a lot of people who maybe didn't do
it this month I didn't prepare for it
they weren't ready for it but they're
doing it next month nice which is
exciting I had somebody reach out and
say did you know about Frugal February
I'm like oh I like that let's like the
sound of that we need to come up with a
word for every single month to where
we're just on a budget every month hey
let's do it if it works then let's do it
and what's really cool is I keep getting
messages from people who are making huge
progress this month they're paying off
debt they're saving in their emergency
see firm they're paying down their house
and I just absolutely love it but I do
want to take a second to kind of talk
about where at the last week what
happens next right because the goal it's
kind of like have you ever done like
Whole30 I've attempted it I can't say I
ever succeeded okay well with the Whole
30 like the goal isn't just to do a diet
for a month right and lose a few pounds
the goal is a lifestyle change and same
with no spin January it's like it's
exciting we're seeing these quick
amazing big wins but we don't want it to
just be this month like how is it going
to last throughout the rest of the year
and I know for our family like we're
already seeing ways that we can
massively change the way we spend our
money and do groceries and it's been
such a good tune-up that I have no doubt
that we're going to be doing a lot
better going forward so I just encourage
all of you who have done it with us to
you know start thinking through how can
we carry this progress forward how can
we carry the momentum and one of the big
things is to set a really clear goal so
for our family you know we want to we're
in the housing market right now houses
in our areas we've talked about are kind
of crazy expensive and we want to pay it
off house so we are just aggressively
saving towards the house so my goal is
by December 31st I will put x amount of
money towards paying the house but I
need it really clear and specific so if
you are in the season of being really
aggressive if you've been doing the no
spend month with me you know really
think through what's your goal that's
going to carry the momentum forward you
know maybe you'll have all your debt
paid off by August or you'll build a
fully funded emergency fund by June but
whatever it is be really clear because
you know I'm one of the things that's
inspiring to me is I've had so many
people in my DMs being like I'm pumped
I'm going to do no spin February I'm
gonna do it in March we're going to do
90 days and that is awesome and I want
you to keep that enthusiasm it is easy
for life to pop up Murphy to show up and
kind of lose that enthusiasm but with
your goal in mind like make it clear and
plain to see and the other thing is to
create a visual so we have this like
perfect spot in our bedroom that we
walked by every single day and that is
the spot for my vision board and where
I'm going to put that goal like huge
where I can see it I gotta is I'm forced
to pass it every time I go in and out of
the room and I've been getting a lot of
like trackers that people are using like
a lot of people have like the bricks
where it's like they they have a brick
for their house and like each time they
like pay a thousand dollars off on their
house they like fill in a brick and I
just love that so you know if it's
helpful to you create a visual where
it's not just like you have this goal
that you can forget tomorrow but you're
seeing it every single day and you know
what you find what you're fighting for
you feel that momentum so I'm just super
excited I feel like 2023 is going to be
such an awesome year and let's go y'all
let's keep this momentum get those
sticky notes on the bathroom mirror put
your affirmations up there whatever you
need to do to stay on track and I'm
going to work on coming up with monthly
names for being on a budget the best I
can do for you right now is miserly
March but I don't like that it's got a
very negative tone to it
yeah that's pretty General though
March there we go
um what about April April's tough I
don't have any a words here I'm looking
at you know synonyms affluent April oh
that's fancy right I like it then we're
back to M for May oh this is too hard
darn we'll come up with it we'll
announce them later on all right let's
get to the phones Rachel joins us up
next in New York City Rachel welcome to
the show
thanks so much I really appreciate you
taking my call absolutely what's going
on with you
well I I've been a little bit careless
uh things have just been really out of
control in life and I did not even
realize that I was in 4 500 of debt
which isn't much
like as far as the grand scheme of
things it's manageable but it's over
three credit cards which I am so excited
to get them paid off closed canceled
done with them forever
but I have a question so they're all
about the same amount I can afford to
pay off within the budget I can pay off
two in full this month the other one
will have to wait until next month I can
make a minimum payment not a big deal
but one of the three has zero percent
interest
it is
in the middle it's like the second most
amount of money would it be
Fair of me to push that one to next
month and pay the two off that have
interest rates what are the balances
um they're ranging between
1200 and 1500. hey Rachel can we back up
for just a second how did you yeah how
did you accidentally get in forty five
hundred dollars of credit card debt
without knowing it
so I like was aware that I was using my
credit cards but I didn't realize what
the balance was I just been very very
careless I'm paying stupid tax as Dave
would say
um for for being careless in the months
leading up to my wedding have you paid
have you cut up those credit cards
I have okay
good I cut them up I've put them in a
frame on my desk okay okay good that's
the level of anger we need there we go I
feel better now now we can proceed I'm
going to pay these off from smallest to
largest and ignore that zero percent
interest rate because I think it's one
of those mental traps that got us here
in the first place and I like the
feeling of still having that one with
interest dangling out there to keep the
fire under you to get rid of it as soon
as possible
that's I I kind of thought that's what
you'd say but I wanted to I wanted to
make sure I was doing it the right way
that's what I would do because I'm a
human and I'm I know I'm not perfect and
I know when I see zero percent I go ugh
I got time next month's fine too though
I mean it'll it'll we'll get rid of it I
love the idea of you looking at 22
interest going I will never do business
with any of these scummy companies again
that's what the feeling I want you to
have yeah pay all the stupid tax
wonderful having them cut up and sitting
on my desk and being like I will be done
with them in two months in two months I
will be completely out of debt and it
won't be a problem but I love it when's
the wedding
uh the wedding was in December oh
now recovering and looking at everything
and we're you know creating our budget
together and all of that good stuff so I
love it so is your spouse on board with
this crazy plan
oh yeah
that's great that's great have you guys
been through Financial Peace University
we have nice well we all we all pay our
stupid tax Rachel so don't feel shame
and guilt we just learn and move on it's
only really stupid if you keep doing it
exactly and keep justifying it but I'm
glad it's in the frame it's in the rear
view mirror and within the next month no
more debt and you're gonna have that
emergency fund real soon and you're
gonna be building for the future instead
of paying for the past
we have our thousand dollar emergency
fund and we had built up an emergency
fund before the wedding between like on
our own and that's what we're using to
clear these starts awesome I love it man
young people getting this stuff
newlyweds it just warms my heart what a
beautiful story love it congrats on soon
to be debt Freedom Rachel this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis and we are excited to take your
calls America to help you take that
right next step in your financial
journey and Harry is on the line in
Detroit Harry welcome to the Ramsey Show
well hi you guys thanks for taking my
call very much
um I've got a friend who's in a real
dire situation he's and he never had
problems with money before autopay he
never had an overdraft before auto pay
he paid his bills manually since autopay
he has had just ridiculous problems with
it and uh and not only do I feel for him
I'm quite scared for myself as well I'm
I have I'm great with money I haven't
had an overdraft in 24 years myself and
I pay my bills on time manually but they
are trying to get me to switch over to
autopay I'm not going to do it I'm
holding out as long as I can how do you
deal with auto pay and this kind of
problem what what exactly like what is
the problem like he's not okay timing it
well or what's what's been the issue
they pull it out whenever they want if
they pull it out sometimes on the 15th
or 18th or 10th or whatever
uh if they pull everything out the same
day my friend it'd be all right but he's
that's the problem that they've had
they've pulled things out they even
double Bill people sometimes these
people whose they is it the bank is it
the like the utility provider who's they
in the city yeah it's the different
companies that they've um
that he's had and so I don't know how to
help them
and I don't even know how to help me
because I'm afraid it could happen to me
in the future here's what I do Harry and
this is anecdotal I've got my all my
utility bills most of everything I can
get on autopay I do it but here's what I
also do I do a monthly budget and I Mark
due dates and inside of every dollar you
can mark the due dates for those bills
so I know exactly when they're coming
out and we also have a new tool inside
of every dollar premium called paycheck
planning where it will show you exactly
when you would run out of money so it's
show your friend when he would overdraft
based on when his bills come out and
what you can do is call the company or
get on their website and you can change
the due date to a very specific date
and uh then you can plan for that in
your budget so if you need that bill to
come out on the 16th because you get
paid on the 15th instead of the 10th you
can move that generally uh to the 16th
to avoid that and you start doing that
with enough bills and use that paycheck
planning tool and you can solve all
these problems I truly do not think it's
auto pay is the enemy I think it is
ourselves and that's a hard pill to
swallow to go I haven't done a good job
managing my bills and my money and also
another thing he needs is a buffer in
his checking account and so instead of
budgeting from zero dollars in his bank
he needs to have a 200 300 buffer
sitting in there and that's kind of the
floor we don't go below 300 every bit of
our income and expenses happens beyond
that 300.
another thing you can do is turn off
overdraft to where the build just won't
go through and you won't get charged
oh that's that's right so you could go
into your banking features and turn that
function off so that you don't get
dinged from the bank and I've done this
before Harry uh you know even in the
past few years we miscalculated
something and I got the overdraft fee
and nothing makes me angrier than an
overdraft fee of 35 so I walk into the
bank and I go listen I've been a
customer for a decade I'm willing to
stop today because of this overdraft fee
and I go all right as a one-time
courtesy we'll refund you the 35 so you
can also get that over draft feedback
back if your bank is nice
how's that sound here everything is all
right yeah um the other thing is I was
going to do that myself with a utility
um because I wanted to switch my payment
uh to the third and I called them and
they said well if you switch to the
third you're going to have a fee uh
every month because uh you're paying it
on the third instead of when we want you
to pay when do they want you to pay it
on the 26th I've never heard the
previous month do you know if it's a c
or are they trying to just like make up
the difference like a prorated amount to
kind of change the date is it an actual
like dinging you a penalty an actual fee
it's yeah it's an actual fee I couldn't
believe it
which utility provider is it
Verizon
okay
um I would maybe try calling back
well if that's the case well I'm gonna
go well I'm gonna have the money on the
26th and I'm gonna gift you every dollar
premium uh I'll give you two of them how
about that one for you and one for your
friend and you guys can have a little
budget party together how's that sound
well I can't see do you need to use your
software but my friend would love it I'm
sure okay we'll make sure to get that
over to you Austin will pick up and
we'll get that over to you but it's a
it's an interesting conversation it is
an interesting conversation and I do
know a lot of that stuff can be kind of
overwhelming like I don't know how how
tech savvy Harry is but I know for my
mom it's a lot like trying to be like
Mom just change it to where this is on
this day and then go to the bank and do
this and then sitting down with her is
really helpful so if there's somebody in
your life if you feel overwhelmed by
trying to get everything set up maybe I
know it can be a tough pill to swallow
sometimes for parents but Millennials
and gen Z were pretty good at Tech or
tip with it we're hip with it and I feel
like we're at the spot now with my mom
with my husband's parents like that's
kind of our role we sit down with them
and we walk them through like how do we
set up things on the right schedule how
do we deal with the technology it can
feel kind of overwhelming but like
walking through it oh yeah that's a good
call love that all right let's go to
Ashley in Chattanooga Ashley welcome to
the show
Hi how are you we're doing great how can
we help today
um I
am I am I I'm trying to find um right
communication
set up finances and you know my
boyfriend and I are considering moving
forward and proposing and getting
married and we just have different views
of finances and so I'm just trying to to
get him on board with savings and what
are history
um he doesn't really have anything it's
kind of frustrating every time I talk
about it he just
um kind of shuts down I mean I just
recently found out
kind of how much money he has in the
bank how much money he makes and we've
been together for almost three years so
it's just is it disconcerting to like
does he have a lot of money in the bank
or does he have nothing
um he has well more than I do um and I
think that he you know from the way his
family is I think he's he's grown up a
little bit more comfortable than my
family as in like he has never had to
worry about having money whereas I have
always had a job and always kind of
lived paycheck to paycheck until I got
my career job
um so and we're both making the most
that we've ever made in our careers so I
just I don't know how to
ask him you know with him making almost
double my salary I think that it's kind
of
I don't really know the wording um
what's the fear on your part
what's the fear um that he that we're
just we're blowing money we're not on
the butt he doesn't so you're saying
he's been out earning his stupidity he's
just kind of doing whatever he wants
because he makes enough that it's not
really a concern is he going into debt
for all this
no no he's great
um that's why I feel bad even asking I
own a home so I own my own home
um he doesn't own a home he lives with
me so I think that was the first
miscommunication or the first how does
that work is he paying you rent
yes but is that wrong I don't know I
don't know how so what I'm not married I
don't what do these conversations look
like like whenever you try to sit them
down and speak about money what does it
look like what does he get defensive
does he get aloof you said he shuts down
at what point does that happen
uh it happened right around
the parking in the other room
um he
he just doesn't he's never open to the
conversation I always have to start it
and he just kind of shakes his head and
does it is he do you think he's
controlling with it he doesn't want
anyone to tell him what to do with his
money yes yes and how do you how do you
start the conversations like how is this
opener to the financial conversation
um so you know there's stuff at the
house that he doesn't love my house and
I you know it's just my first home and I
feel
um pretty proud of it you should be
Ashley
you tell him to kick rocks and pound
sand if he doesn't want to live there
and it's part of the reason this is so
messy is because when you shack up and
play house it usually doesn't end well
and so we need to have some really hard
conversations with this guy and say
listen I can see a future with you but
not if we don't rely on this money stuff
and not if you're not willing to talk
about it
and I would also suggest premarital
counseling because it sounds like there
may be some deeper issues the fact that
he's willing to say those sort of things
that kind of brings shame to your
housing situation that you're really
proud of I'd really dig into those roots
before you marry this absolutely I mean
money fights and money problems are one
of the leading causes of divorce and so
I would tread lightly with this guy I
hope the best for you I would go through
Financial Peace University I would gift
that to you guys right now so hang on
the line Austin will pick up if he's
unwilling to go through financial peace
it's a big red flag to me and I would
pause with this relationship and it
might mean it's time to kick this guy
out thanks for the call Ashley that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books my thanks to Christina Ellis and
you America
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]